after Air Force one landed in Israel
Donald Trump reached for milania's hand
and she slapped it away yeah
there's video of it which so does and
she slaps it away so we've been wrong
all this time they apparently do have a
normal marriage that is yeah that is me
that's that's how it goes when I get
home hi honey Wow
it is true Donald Trump reached for
milania's hand and she batted it away
yeah it's the first time a first lady
has smacked a president since every day
of Bill Clinton's administration that's
a record that is a record no too soon
huh okay in both Israel and Saudi Arabia
many US journalists are being barred
from Trump press events because they're
women yeah as opposed to here in the US
where they're barred from Trump press
events because they're journalists so
I liked your reaction that was really
funny kind of more sad and true than
anything else but it's hot outside so
I'll clap cuz the air conditionings free
a company has released a GPS with
president Trump's voice as a navigator
it doesn't guide you anywhere it just
keeps reminding you that it won the
electoral college Hillary Clinton
advisor Huma Abedin is divorcing her
husband disgraced former Congressman
Anthony Weiner
divorce yeah that's right ladies he's
single you want to leave now you know
last night the Ringling Brothers Circus
gave its final performance yeah yeah
children children everywhere were
stunned and said what's a circus
scientists have discovered that alcohol
does not actually change a person's
personality but just makes them louder
is that amazing Andi sure is Conan
[Music]
that was Andy Richter as the drunk yeah
I can feel the Emmy in my hand yeah
you